a tree that bleeds and if less than 10%
of your asparagus contains beetle eggs
it's good to eat Vsauce Kevin here this
is mind blow
many claim Castlevania to Simon's quest
as the first game to feature multiple
endings which would be true except for a
certain blonde bikini bounty hunter and
here's a backyard bounty on earth check
out this guy's desk pretty nice computer
looks like one of those new flat panels
no this isn't Final Fantasy 7 for the
intended 64 but a playable tech demo
made by Squaresoft to show 3d battles
using characters from Final Fantasy 6
owned at Final Fantasy 7 were on the n64
it would have been a million cartridges
or 13 let's talk video game music we've
all heard that some of the music in
Sonic 3 might have been composed by
Michael Jack but how about the Mega Man
and journey connection
[Music]
or Chrono Trigger getting well
a bird that can mimic cameras a field
that's under a lake and a jungle inside
a cave this mammoth cavern in Vietnam
could fit an entire new york city block
of 40 story buildings it contains a
river and golem
not really whoa check out this key light
melody making game that saves itself in
the URL so you can make a song and set
it to Grandpa Louie
thanks for the song Billy Milo 3 brought
us 12 months in Estonian foxface wood
and blade 77 courtesy of facebook.com
slash vsauce gaming now brings us as in
russian cut oh and harpoon backwards is
no Oprah I'm gonna leave you guys with a
riddle first of all congratulations to
PC Alex for solving last week's riddle
the answer was Sunday ok here we go the
first person to get the real write and
explain how they got their answer will
be featured at the top of these sauces
channel page as our genius of the week
named an eight-letter word that has K s
T in the middle in the beginning and at
the end I think you know it leave your
answer in the comments below and as
always thanks for watching
when they breached eyeballs he's a spy
from catapult I'm all that and I just
decide what is shillings I
[Music]